in this video I'm going to be building a
full set of screen accurate stormtrooper
armor but I only have one month to
finish it because I'm also going to be
running an entire 5K in public in the
armor I wouldn't recommend doing that in
all I spend over a thousand dollars on
tools and materials this is so expensive
and it took over 40 hours to build
everything but it all started with a
brown box
it's here
let's get started building stormtrooper
armor involves three main steps trimming
sanding and gluing of course there's
also lots of painting and drilling
involved but most of that comes from the
helmet now you might be wondering why
I'm doing this and it's because I love
Star Wars
ever since I was a kid I've been in love
with the franchise and I've always
dreamed of having my very own
stormtrooper armor also the armor gives
me an opportunity to join a group called
The 501st Legion a worldwide
organization of volunteers that's
dedicated to building screen accurate
Star Wars costumes and giving back to
their communities my local 501st
Garrison has strong ties to several
Charities so I wanted to make this armor
as screen accurate as possible so I can
join the 50 First in helping their
charity work during all of this though
my biggest issue was time
guys I don't think I'm gonna have enough
time to finish this in case you forgot I
only have a month to finish this armor
because I've already signed up for a 5K
and Enlisted the help of my brother to
run alongside me since I'm not actually
sure if I'll be able to see in the armor
let alone run let's get some advice from
a more experienced Trooper in the 501st
to see if they can give me any pointers
for running a 5k
hello hey Dustin it's Riley hey Riley so
Dustin I had a couple questions about
the Stormtrooper build that I'm doing
and I was wondering if you could answer
them for me yeah sure go ahead okay so
what's it like to wear the armor and how
much visibility do you have I would say
it's not too uncomfortable
issue
okay well
well planning on running a 5k in my set
so what would your thoughts be on that
5K
[Music]
I wouldn't
do you think it's possible I mean yeah
it's probably possible but I wouldn't
now that I know it's possible let's get
back to building the clock was still
ticking so I got straight to building
the legs I think I'm getting pretty good
at this guys two weeks in I'd only
finished the arms and the legs so I only
had two more weeks to finish the chess
piece the back the Cod the entire helmet
and strap it all together it was taking
a really long time because I kept having
to check reference photos to ensure I
was building the armor up to the 501st
legion standards and I wasn't able to
work on the armor during the day because
I was busy working at my full-time job
so I only had time to build late at
night at this point I was getting pretty
worried I wouldn't finish on time for
the 5K I started to get overwhelmed and
uncertain there were a few times I would
spend hours working on a piece of armor
only to realize that I had made a
mistake and would need to start all over
again I started the question whether I
was even capable of doing something as
difficult as this and then disaster
struck so I was up basically all night
last night becoming best friends with my
toilet
so now I'm super dehydrated and I don't
feel like doing anything I'm super
behind on the armor build and it doesn't
look like I'm gonna get it done on time
but as the deadline approached
except defeat or push through and finish
what I started and that's when things
started to turn around I got a Dremel
now take a look at this bad boy this
right here is called a Dremel it is
absolutely saving and getting this
project done on time let's get to work
with the help of the Dremel I was able
to trim down the parts way faster this
tool completely changed my mindset and I
got into a really good group I blasted
through the chest back and cod in just a
week and it was starting to look like I
might actually get it done in time
it's almost done thumbs up
[Music]
the only bad thing about the Dremel is
the ear piercing sound it makes
although it hurt my ears I was able to
get the hardest part of the build the
helmet done in just four days
[Music]
wow that looks great the ears took
forever but I was finally able to get
them to look how I want now all that's
left is cutting out a few small pieces
and attaching to the armor
[Music]
and with that after an entire month it
was finally done
[Music]
it looks incredible I am so happy with
the way the armor turned out and I
couldn't believe that I actually got it
done on time
thank you
through all the cuts blisters and really
late nights I had finally fulfilled my
dream of having my very own stormtrooper
armor and as I'm editing this video I
just got confirmation that I've been
approved to join the 50 first so be on
the lookout for me at upcoming charity
events but now that it was all finished
it was time to start training for my
true rival the 5K will I be able to run
the entire way in this clunky armor
okay I gotta take this off